I think a lot of us overlooked how good
Sean Strickland is I think we
underestimate his will to not only win
and beat a guy like Izzy but definitely
isn't scared in any facet but also Sean
Strickland and Rogue mentioned this on
the fight companion most of us knew this
but at that level in in the UFC they did
all this testing on who gets hit the
least and who gets hit the most in
training camp and Sean Strickland was by
far number one when I heard that I said
this on the the broadcast with Rogan I
said well who's he sparring because if
you're telling me it's like a Seinfeld
Kramer situation where he's just beating
up 10 year olds and I'm like ah it
doesn't count who's the next guideline
and who's he trading with but if even if
you would have told me Izzy's the least
hit guy in training camp my just
follow-up questions well who are they
competing against turns out Sean
Strickland's competing against some
pretty tough people and that's not
something to overlook the guy doesn't
get hit it's remarkable it is insane